michel mora legault rendez vous c'est
vendredi soir en meeting dans quel état
d'esprit on à bord de ce championnat
devant son public alors ce championnat
je là je laborde très sereinement
là je suis vraiment ressources et je
suis sur mon île je sais que je suis
chez moi je compte sur la ferveur des
antilles eve des martiniquais pour venir
me supporter et très sincèrement je suis
très très bien l'adversaire quelles sont
les informations que vous avez quels
sont ses points faibles et comment vous
construisez votre combat alors son
premier point faible c'est de se
présenter devant moi alors je sais pas
si fondamentalement c'est réellement un
point faible mais voilà il vient se
présenter devant moi pour me prendre mon
titre alors je vais pas dedans je vais
pas vous la accueillir avec le sourire
disons maintenant on a travaillé sur le
peu de vidéos que nous avons vu sur
internet des points faibles il égalera
galliaerde aux tout simplement diego
diaz gallardo égal à lui-même
voilà qui va se frotter à michel
mothmora le boxeur est ce que le fait
d'évoluer devant son public c'est un
enjeu particulier ça change ça décuple
vos forces
alors décuplée m'efforce oui par moments
l'engouement et la ferveur
quand le public sent si jamais ça
m'arrive que j'ai une petite baisse de
régime j'avoue que c'est
c'est plaisant se sentir soutenu
maintenant l'enjeu non parce que je me
mets vraiment dans une bulle
j'ai un objectif c'est de garder mon
titre mondial
et peu importe ce qui se passe autour
voilà cela n'interfère pas dans mon
objectif et je reste bien concentré sur
ce que j'ai à faire
le fait d'être le champion du monde et
de voir quelqu'un venir se positionner
en je veux ce titre s'augmente les
chances que vous le conserviez que vous
battez pour l'avoir pour le garder alors
ce qui peut augmenter et qui a augmenté
les chances qui a fait que je me suis
entraîné encore plus fort que toutes mes
préparations
c'est sa grande langue fourchue qui dit
qu'il va mettre ko on va régler ça sur
le ring